[Music]
when cows and other ruminants eat their
feet ferments in their stomach when
digested and a number of gases are
produced including methane
the animals expel this gas through
burping
that sounds innocent enough except that
methane is a greenhouse gas and a major
contributor to global warming
with an estimated 1.5 billion cows in
the world and 2 billion sheep and goats
it's a big problem and one that climate
action cannot ignore
while methane has a much lower
atmospheric lifespan than carbon dioxide
around 12 years compared to thousands of
years it is a much more powerful
greenhouse gas trapping 86 times more
heat than carbon dioxide over a 20-year
period and contributing strongly to
Global temperature rise
globally digestive or enteric methane
emissions are equivalent to about 3.3
gigatons of carbon dioxide equivalents
that'll account for 77 of these
emissions Buffalo 13 with smaller
livestock making up the rest
so how do we reduce enteric methane
emissions
across the world more and more countries
are including livestock specific
interventions to reach the Paris
agreement targets and sustainable
development goals limiting Global
temperature rise there is a way we can
increase their productivity and reduce
their emissions and that's by adopting
more sustainable farming practices
we can improve ruminance diets through
better grazing management changing
plaster types use of specific feed
additives and supplementing grazing with
forage mixes
adequate feed preparation and ration
balancing provide better nutrition in
turn improving ruminant productivity and
fertility
better husbandry practices Inc in taking
better care of animals monitoring their
health and intervening when signs of
illness occur can also greatly increase
their productivity and reduce their
emissions
[Music]
improving a herd's genetic stock through
selective breeding can also make a
difference
breeding animals that are better adapted
to their surroundings and conditions
including climate and diseases makes
them more resilient and generally more
productive
as countries have different farming
practices and production systems methods
of reducing emissions vary from one
territory to another and must be
country-specific to be effective
taking steps to increase production and
reduce enteric methane emissions is not
only beneficial to The Climate but can
also improve farmers livelihoods
FAO and partners are working with
countries to assess their greenhouse gas
emissions and identify climate smart
actions in the livestock sector these
interventions can increase livestock
productivity improve food security and
livelihoods and reduce enteric methane
emissions they are also providing
guidance to decision makers to
incentivize livestock producers to adopt
Technology Innovation and best practices
that enhance productivity
through sustainable Livestock systems we
can support climate action that not only
benefits millions of people dependent on
livestock production but our entire
planet
foreign